the world of fan right if you you're a
fan girl right now let's just be a fan
girl who is it that has sparked
such a high level of excitement for you
in the business
what actors actresses
directors like what where where do you
go oh
that creative makes me wanna i can't
wait
oh i wanna do that
who's done that for you
um
i had i had a small part and this is
just the first thing that came to my
head because there's probably a better
answer for this but
uh i played
de niro's daughter
in a movie
and
i was only in it for like five minutes
but he was so nice to me and it's a cool
movie but like it it wasn't
it wasn't something that um
i even really like remember like i was i
was barely in it but then like in
retrospect you did get to work with de
niro dude it's huge
and like in that moment he was shy and
nervous and he was like
i'm not going to do a deniro impression
but
i would love it if you do want to do one
if you do one i'll do one
i'll give you i mean luckily it doesn't
even have to be like a general one i
have a moment that i remember that he
was like
oh yeah i mean it's really nice to meet
you um you know thank you for doing this
uh
and i was like no
you don't i mean me thinks um and
whatever
and he was just like okay yeah okay
i'll see you later i was like okay
my deniro moment we were doing a movie
called grudge match
um it's sylvester stallone robert de
niro
all right i'm kevin hart this is when
things are starting to go i'm about to
work with robert de niro yeah and
sylvester stallone
okay
oh
let me make sure i'm prepared
okay i'm going the day before i'm like
i'm going over my line this is how this
is how big of a deal you see my my tone
dropped yeah suddenly you're like i'm
going over my lines why am i whispering
which is why do i want this to be a
secret uh so i'm going over my lines i'm
so excited like this is a big deal i
show up to set man
and i'll never forget i never [ __ ]
forget i like you know i got it all i'm
i'm off book i'm ready
and i get there
and sylvester stallone
him and robert they're like they're well
i call him bobby that's what they call
him right right sylvester stallone and
bobby they're on set and they're talking
and i get there and i'm like hey wow
hey guys you know this is this is crazy
very nice hey hey man very funny guy
very nice to me
first scene
first scene we do it
and i'm so excited because i nailed it
right this is i'm working with the two
legends i'm like this is a big deal this
is a big deal man a big deal [ __ ] yeah
after the scene
i go over to talk to him
and
uh you know i just want to talk you know
robert de niro was sitting in his chair
like this and i couldn't i couldn't see
him from like you know from the back
because he's sitting in the chair so i'm
behind him i just see him sitting like
this and i was like hey man you know i
just want to say
this is such a big deal like for me to
be doing this and he's not moving he's
not doing anything and i like coming
around
and
he was asleep
[Laughter]
he was just sleeping
he didn't hear [ __ ] i said i poured out
my heart for like 20 seconds
and i remember he woke up he's i'm sorry
kid what'd you say i was like what i was
like never mind
i'll just tell you later but he was the
nicest guy
he was so warm so welcoming god i know
exactly how i would film that
so it starts on you and it's just you
like the first three
sentences of what that is and so you
just want to know what this guy's
thinking gee whiz mr de niro and the
whole time you just have his shoulder a
little bit dirty over the front exactly
and you just see like you're right there
and you're about to walk up you take
your last little step forward at the
very end and then he's like
just sleeping but he he woke up so fast
was so cool
he's a gracious insane very beautiful
yeah very i just remember i remember
they never made me feel like
uh i was lesser than
right like they never made me feel like
and they could have absolutely kidding
but no it's the truth like this is this
is like you know i mean i don't know
what movie this was that i did but this
is it's such a huge deal for me but yeah
to them at the time you know they're
they're doing another movie they could
have not wanted to talk they could have
been in their own space their own head
but they made me feel like i was a part
of the cast yeah that was one of the
biggest things for me
seeing people with that level have you
had someone get super stoked around you
and you've had to be like oh my god i'm
gonna make sure that this is like a good
experience even though maybe i'm like
busy in this moment but you're like hey
i [ __ ] see that you're having like a
thing and hi i've never
i've never y yes
but i've never been like offset by it
like i've i've had it
um
but i can say i've also i've never had a
bad experience
with an actor or actress
like i've never i've never in my career
had a bad experience with an actor
actress like [ __ ] or never right not
one have you ever had a bad experience
where you felt like oh these people are
[ __ ] you have to say names oh my god
i've had so many
i've had an unbelievable great segue oh
yeah actually kevin uh 90 of my
interactions with the business i hate
everyone yes you feel like
you feel like you've had a lot you feel
like you've had a shitload of them know
um i've totally worked with people uh
that have been either a disappointing
because maybe i like thought they were
gonna be cooler or
that have just been bafflingly not nice
and [ __ ] nice who cares just like not
taking from this experience what they
could be taking and therefore kind of
just up their own asses and like not
nice fine but like more importantly not
here with us
and that's like on them
[Music]
you